[Musique]
après le lancement du nouveau dispositif
d'insertion sociale r plus il y à un
mois
c'est aujourd'hui qu'a eu lieu la
signature des premiers contrats cette
allocation d'insertion et de retour à
l'emploi a pour objectif d'accompagner
les bénéficiaires du rsa dans leurs
démarches d'insertion
il favorise ainsi le retour à l'activité
tout en ayant la possibilité de
maintenir le niveau des allocations avec
les revenus d'activité séduit par ce
dispositif
de nombreux candidats ont souhaité faire
partie de ces premières signatures
pendant deux mois nous avons reçu 2 500
personnes qui se sont manifestées
intéressé par le dispositif et a+ et sur
les 500 balles et 15 premières personnes
signent cet après midi c'est le début
d'un long cycle et moi je souhaite peut
vraiment qu'on puisse réussir cela parce
que ça permet pas encore une fois de
faire reculer le chômage
le chômage n'est pas une fatalité le
département et ses partenaires lutte
pour la céation durable du contrat de
formation dont le médico-social à
l'emploi salariale dans le domaine de la
petite enfance ses dix sept
bénéficiaires du rsa ont vu en ce
dispositif une opportunité à ne pas
manquer pour construire leur avenir et
concrétiser leur projet comme lisa
dijoux aujourd'hui en contrat
d'apprentissage
j'ai bien là je vais faire une formation
fait un contrat d'apprentissage en
secrétariat médical et ensuite plus tard
j'aimerais enfin j'ai passé par cette
passerelle là pour faire
assistante dentaire vu que j'avais pas
le niveau bac et à passer mon bac
du coup bah ça me permet de
de passer par la case apprentissage qui
est rémunéré et qui me permet de
toujours payer mon loyer ce venir aux
besoins de mon enfant mais département
compte accompagner 5000 réunionnais sur
la voie de l'insertion durable grâce à
ce dispositif d'innovation sociale
r plus franchement il faudrait pas
hésiter parce que c'est c'est une super
opportunité
[Musique]